your East Coast exclusively pretty much
yeah yeah New York is that just it's so
funny because I was so East Coast for so
many years and then came yeah I know
this way I remember and uh yeah that's
right you greeted me as I landed you
were at the American Airlines gate
actually I saw you once at the airport
in New York uh probably I don't know how
old your oldest child is but you had a
newborn in your arms yeah and it was
like after a red eye from La yeah and we
had done your show a couple times and
and I was like look there's Conan
O'Brien you're holding a newborn yeah it
wasn't my baby yeah it was definitely
your baby
they were just giving them out on the
fight you know yeah oh like it was first
class you get a baby if you want no I
didn't want to say hi I didn't want to
say hi but you didn't no I didn't say hi
because you were it was like a red eye
it was six in the morning
yeah and now I feel like I would say hi
to you if I saw you at six in the
morning and you were holding a newborn I
love randomly bumping into people that I
adore I remember so clearly coming off I
think a red eye and going into JFK and
there's this one specific part of the
airport I'm walking through and I bump
right into literally almost ran into
Paul Rudd oh amazing I remembered he was
holding a guitar case because he was
working on on on his guitar playing and
we bumped into each other and we had
this really great conversation and now
every time I passed that part of the JFK
a terminal when I'm walking through
which I am all the time I I think of
like this romantic moment
yeah and he's told me that he thinks of
it too that's sweet you should recreate
it yeah I think we should just marry him
yeah thank you no one you know what
nobody dislikes Paul right and I've been
searching because I'm one I'm determined
to find something totally true yeah
there's some people all red and Dolly
Parton oh my God yeah nobody dislikes
have you worked with Dolly I I have
before yeah you have creeping in with
Dolly parties yeah and she came and
saying with us at the Ryman and I got to
sing one of her songs with her okay
that's just crazy but this is forever
ago and um I I mean she's the best it
doesn't matter if it's forever ago it
happened she's the best she is the best
she's the best and the funniest you
should have Dolly on yes no no I'm not
ready she's not ready yet she's ready
she needs to prove herself a little more
in the world of Music yes
yeah it will happen Adam it's going to
happen please but one of my favorite
things this reminds me of when you host
a show people are always suggesting
guests yeah early days of my late night
show there was a guy who
um I can't remember what I think he was
from Central America and his job was to
sort of be the guard that stood on the
way into the elevators at 30 Rock to get
into our part of the building where the
offices were I remember this guy was
very nice he was very young and uh I
think his name was like Luis I think and
I'd come in and he'd be like oh hello
Conan good to see you and I said oh hi
Louise you know have a good day I
remember when I came by once and he said
hey Conan and I said yes he said the
Rolling Stones are in town and I said oh
that I know Luis it's been in all the
papers and he said I think they'd be
pretty good on your show
yes Luis they would be amazing on the
show but the Rolling Stones are the
biggest musical act in the world and
they don't do shows like mine any and um
also if they were going to do a show
they'd probably do like a big 11 30 show
like Letterman and I'm a 12 30 show and
you know we've only been on a few years
so they wouldn't probably come on my
show and he looked at me and he Shrugged
and he went I think that'd be good
so sweet like I was blowing him off
you're missing enough you're right
you like Mick Jagger was on the phone
like come on
no that's funny if somebody told me I
should have Billy eilish on my podcast
and I was like that would be amazing I I
don't know if she would want to do my
podcast
that's the nice thing is you are in that
sweet spot of
um I just think a new act uh an act
that's been around for a hundred years
anyone's going to want to do your
podcast yeah well thanks not anyone but
I I'm I'm I'm let me talk to them Utah
you be my liaison please
give me Billy Ellis you're gonna do
Norah Jones see who am I Conan O'Brien
from television well not anymore
television but used to be television I
understand you there are you there
yes maybe I shouldn't do that do that
for me yeah I was having dinner with
Nick Offerman and Megan Mullally and one
of someone looked over and in a far
Corner booth
was Dolly oh wow oh wow and I know Dolly
because I think she did the Late Night
show once or twice
and
they are both like can you bring us over
and introduce us to Dolly Parton and it
was just so it was like going to say
hello to the pope yeah actually
I'm going to save higher than the pope
whoa well I'm sorry yeah you are very
your family especially yeah very
Catholic yeah but there's a lot of popes
they keep replacing them you're right
there's only one yeah there's been like
175 popes right then they had two popes
at the same time right so
I'm sorry the the pope like the Euro has
been devalued there's just too many of
them being too many of them are being
minted but there's only one Dolly Parton
it's true and very man is she she's the
best she is the nicest person we were
all like
quaking in our boots and she couldn't
have been uh a More Beautiful Soul she's
very giving with herself like her her
personality and everything you know also
she has never
she's always of the time yeah in this
crazy way which is so if you you know in
the 60s 70s 80s 90s like right now
wisdom from her is as precious
as it's ever been and and or or her
doing a musical performance it's just
kind of neat how she sort of transcends
time I don't know how she does this
she's great well she just got inducted
to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
she she thought it was kind of funny
because she says she's not a rock and
roll musician but she did it anyway and
she's very gracious about it and now
she's made a rock and roll album oh
really I think as a sort of uh like you
know I might as well and I think that's
pretty awesome I almost feel like nine
to five is kind of a rock and roll song
yeah I mean genre I mean so much she
definitely deserved it but yeah yeah
every rock and roll song that has
typewriter for percussion oh that's
right yes yeah that's so cool we just
had
um it'll have already been out I think
by the time but Jane Fonda sat in that
chair oh my God a couple days ago and we
got on the topic of Dolly Parton and she
spoke of her as if she was the you know
I mean she idolizes Dolly Parton and uh
told these really great stories about
her
so it's Dolly week get Conan
thanks uh you know what I we've all
wanted Dolly but Adam sacks is forbidden
it for now yeah yeah
there's one track she cut in 1973 that
Adam sacks didn't quite like now that
Norah Jones has blessed it oh
go to
go to her go to the light if we do book
her and you have to travel will you let
me and Gorly Go I mean sometimes you
don't let us come well I have to come as
the caveat oh you can come yeah yeah oh
look Let Me Explain If I'm going to talk
to like a you know Barack Obama or
someone there are security issues
involve background checks and that's why
you've jury usually excluded right you
know what you did and you know what you
did four times
um yeah I mean yeah but you're a
shoplifter oh okay are you
we're striking okay all right oh okay
all right okay what could you did Nora
opposed this was fine you know what
happened uh gorley's been getting a
little more feisty we all know that and
Son Of course always just a terror but
you come in and you and you praise them
both and now they're insane they're like
we're gonna throw us
yeah it's fun